I think the story got a little bit
overblown a little bit
um but I mean I'm intrigued if some of
that technology ever comes to fruition I
I I'm obviously going to be all eyes to
see it you know how you mentioned you
have about three and a half million
pages that are online I presume you
haven't had a chance to go through each
of those pages because that's a lot yeah
that's almost 500 a day so how do you
make heads and tails of it yeah so a lot
of a lot of documents I get that are
sometimes more historical uh historical
records 300 400 Pages unless I'm really
interested in reading that book
sometimes I just will scan it put it
online or if I get a digital you know
put it online so no I I would not
pretend to say I've read all 3.3
whatever million Pages it is now uh
myself but that also is is kind of my
aim with this is to give others access
to it I've gotten letters over the years
from people that read obscure documents
that I forgot I posted about you know
years prior and I love that kind of
stuff because what what means nothing to
me is gold to somebody else and I love
that yeah and soon you'll be able to use
a large language model to crawl through
it
yeah OCR has to get a little bit better
for that I I'm really excited about the
implications behind it but some of these
older documents that are you know
decades old and old typewriters OCR has
to be incredibly strong to decipher all
of that text for a machine to to
essentially make sense of it all right
we have something super large to
announce and I want to take you through
the whole thought process so firstly
let's talk about how is it that I came
up with 500 because many people are
interested in these napkin calculations
so John said that hey there's 3.5
million pages so I just round it up to
3.65 million Pages why so that I can
divide it cleanly by the amount of days
in a year 365. divide that that's 10
000. now he said that he's been doing
this for 27 years or so or 26 maybe even
25 so what I've did is just reduce that
to 20 and then divide that so that's
approximately 500. there's a whole video
on just doing physics calculations and
how you can calculate the size of a
black hole for instance from just a
napkin calculation we also talk about
why the wave function is not a function
how to approximate the length of an atom
how to calculate the pressure in a
neutron star all right now on to the
announcement a machine learning website
which was inspired by John saying that
he has a multitude of foia documents
that aren't indexed I wanted to create
an app that actually uses the latest AI
to crawl through his documents but there
were problems John said that there were
millions of pages I remember thinking
there's no way John they can be million
no there are millions of pages and
they're extremely large they're strewn
across several servers and hard drives
remember that this is 26 27 years of
John's life keep that in mind all that
I'm doing is that I'm coming in and
saying hey John your documents you've
gathered them for decades some are
searchable and some aren't you had so
much intensity and stress and you had
ardency placed into these documents the
retrieval of them and then showcasing
them why not showcase it to people in a
more efficient manner or how can I help
with that why not use The Cutting Edge
of machine learning to bring that to
more people if you have any examples
if there's anything that you could send
over that you've seen on my site that
you feel is kind of Representative of
what you feel would be used in such a
model I would love to help I just am not
a hundred percent sure if those
documents would be worthwhile to you so
anyway I'll stop blabbing but hopefully
that gives a little bit better of an
impression I'm around tomorrow if you
want to chat I'm driving right now if
you can't tell I'm going to pick up my
son uh and then heading over to my
daughter's school for a dance recital so
daddy duties kind of kicking in so
anyway I look forward to hearing from
you and I'll hopefully talk to you soon
all right now at this point of the
conversation with John I said hey I'd
love for there to be an integration of a
large language model with your PDFs why
doesn't this exist then I thought like
hey I have some coding skills they're
not terribly efficient but why not try
and create this myself so then what
happened was I ran into certain hurdles
like I was watching videos on hey here's
how to chat with your documents and I
thought that this would be what I need
but it's more like here's how to train a
large language model to mimic the style
and some of the knowledge but not
precisely of the documents and I wanted
it to be factual I wanted it to cite
specific PDFs if you ask it a question a
question like what types of metals did
the US government find at crash sites I
wanted to bring up well here document
number three says this and here's a PDF
that talks about this and it shows the
excerpts not just surmise or confabulate
which large language models seem to do
then I'm like okay this is much more
complicated than I thought let me
contact an actual startup developer
who's working on something similar we
had a conversation nice to meet you nice
to meet you as well thank you for taking
this call I appreciate it I've been
looking for a service where I can give
it a set of PDFs would like to be able
to with natural language have people
query it well for instance if you say
can you find an inconsistency in the
document about the weight of a box then
it'll say yes I found that on document
two it says the weight is 30 pounds but
on document 40 it says the weight is 80
pounds no I mean
um your first example might be a little
tricky I'm not sure we'll have to test
it out but the second one is like a
perfect use case uh for like you know
semantic search or like uh document q a
which is what we do he seemed to be
going through with this but then turns
out that this project was a bit more
intricate than what he was developing so
we had to not go through with that and
I'm thinking okay come on I want to
release this episode for you all I want
to come out with this tool this would be
fantastic if when this podcast premieres
with John there's this tool that the
community that people are interested in
uaps can actually use so I was dismayed
and then I remembered hey I went to this
conference in Florida this mindfest
conference where there were several
extremely competent people who are
experts in machine learning and in fact
there was one that stood Out Among the
rest and we became friends his name is
Dan VanZant it's a fantastic name Daniel
Van Zant and he has the company called
cephalopod AI Solutions so I contacted
Dan and I told him my frankly insulting
budget which is essentially nothing but
then he decided he's like you know what
Kurt I'll work with you because I
believe in this project and he also has
some familiarity with foyer requests
himself which we'll talk about from what
I understand from you the MVP is just a
person can put in a text query and a
tragedy PT style way get a chat GPT
style answer text files that are linked
to the PDFs and so that won't be a huge
issue I'm curious how these files are
named we're gonna need to have the total
data size and and the approximate amount
of pages we have I don't think there's
been too many people that are more
altruistically motivated like you who
are making for your requests yeah I'll
think about it one feature that you have
mentioned that would be fairly easy to
implement is the trends are these
documents dated at all how many queries
do you think this is going to be getting
say in like the first two months or
something and then how many do you think
it's going to have in one day at its
height that's important for load
balancing it's at this point that I
asked Daniel about his experience with
foia requests I'm decently familiar with
foyer requests because our my lab
actually makes them quite frequently
it's amazing the things that we'll think
of as we're kind of on the Cutting Edge
of the AI and we'll find out oh the
military did this 20 years ago and they
just haven't told anyone about it till
now they were using microsulated
computers for weapon systems and based
on what they can Target so like these
large guns on battleships and things
like that and and to us and to the field
this was like a brand new undeveloped
idea some people had done something with
it at some point but but the military
just casually came back at us and
basically told us yeah we've been
working with this for for 20 or 30 years
and we've been working with it enough
that we're able to show you the early
parts of it which I assume means they're
they're Way Beyond whatever they started
with and by the way there are time
stamps in all these videos you can
always skip to sections that you like I
think it'll be extremely fruitful to
understand the process and mindset that
went into creating this tool that you're
about to see so that you can understand
the context and see where it may lead to
another hurdle was that we had to take
these PDFs or Dan had to and then
convert them to text txt files and yet
to create certain efficient prompts for
that and because they're scanned
documents so it's large in size and it's
difficult to read as well for people let
alone a computer so we contacted some
people who had or claimed to have
ready-made Solutions IBM was one of them
we contacted them had several meetings
with IBM with some of their tools and I
thought that they would have a free
version of their tool or just a couple
hundred USD like 500 USD after meeting
with them so many back and forth they
said hey for the minimum amount it's 5
000 USD and I was just like so so
disappointed like oh my gosh man why is
this so difficult and that's just the
first stage five thousand dollars for
this we contacted another developer
working with them closely and then they
said okay here's the cost it's 180
000 I'm not even kidding you one hundred
and eighty thousand dollars for a year
of this service so which is actually a
great service a fantastic one it's
almost exactly what we're looking for
except far out of our budget far out of
our budget I would say functionality
Wise It's about done uh what I've been
doing today is I've been doing some load
balancing and some other things like
that really boring infrastructure type
things but they still take a decent
amount of work uh to make sure that it
can handle about 4 000 requests per day
because that's it's not huge but that's
a pretty substantial amount it should be
pretty much ready to go as long as you
think the UI looks good when you see
YouTube videos on here's how to do
something with the llm most of the time
they're over hyped and they're for
specific use cases and you have to use
many different programs and many of them
have interoperability issues anyway what
we've done is we've scaled back the
project scope significantly so rather
than it being all of John's work we've
made it a percentage of a percentage and
we've done so by crawling and focusing
specifically on the UFO aspect because
many of his foia requests don't pertain
to that now without further Ado here is
the tool
hello there my name is Daniel Van Zant I
am the owner of cephalopod AI Solutions
and I am so excited to present this new
tool at collaboration with John
Greenwald of The Black Vault and courage
among theories of everything
and so John Greenwald uh has spent years
collecting this really awesome resource
of Freedom of Information Act requested
documents and Kurt had this idea and
came to me about implementing it
on what if we made this an AI database
uh what if we harness this new power of
llms like chat vpt to be able to talk to
the database get answers and almost
compose a mini research report for the
user as opposed to the user having to
search through each PDF themselves and
slog through it and
make it harder to see patterns
and so I will jump right into things
here
and just show you how it works
so I can ask it any question I think
that I'll ask it a question about UFOs
I'm going to ask it what are the main
types
uh the UFO sightings
and so it takes a little bit uh but
what it's going to do is it's going to
go to that database and it's going to
dynamically find
part of those PDFs uh in the database
that could answer this question
PDFs don't have to have exact keywords
they just have to be related somehow and
so it's already come up with an answer
and it says there are various types of
UFO sightings the most common are
reports of astronomical sightings
uh it's got close range sightings on the
ground
are most intriguing most UFO sightings
can be attributed to the
misidentification of known objects and
phenomena so you're going to notice that
it says snippet 12 snip it six snippet
two snippet 3. these are references to
these and so you can see a shortened
version of all of these Snippets down
here
and if you click on them so it's time to
snippet six on the Extraterrestrial
hypothesis that sounds kind of
interesting I'm going to go down and I'm
going to click on snippet6 and it's
going to show me the full context that
it dynamically chose to feed into the
lll
uh and so here it is it's somewhat ugly
because we ocr'd a bunch of PDFs and
they're just not a way to do that well
without getting some ugly text
especially when the Pediatric stands but
it's still very much readable
all right I
can see what it says Kish suits
uh
Stars bright celestial objects are Main
culprits and UFO sightings they've
fooled many Advanced observers even
Pilots oh that's interesting
and so I'm gonna look at this and I'm
gonna see that it mentions Airmen it
mentions Pilots
uh and I'm going to ask it
have there been
any
extraterrestrial
sightings from
the Air Force
because that seems quite interesting to
me and so you can see I was able to ask
a question I was able to get a summary I
was able to go down to the snippet I was
interested in and then I was able to use
that to generate another question
and this has been one of my favorite
things to do even as I've just been
developing this
is getting into it and getting deeper
and deeper into the questions I don't
know if you've ever gotten lost on
Wikipedia or you've ever gotten lost
Googling and learning about something
but it's a similar type of feeling
and so it popped up with something
according to Simply one of the Air Force
has investigated over 10 000 reports of
UFOs in the United States
found no evidence they represent
extraterrestrial vehicles
snippet 2 mentions major Donald Kehoe
uh he believes that the Air Force is
withholding information by
extraterrestrial signings that's kind of
interesting
and so I'm going to look at what this
says
so he thinks that the Air Force was
withholding information for fear of
causing a public Panic that sounds kind
of interesting
and then snippet6 suggests the Pentagon
has been involved in UFO research and
may release documents related to the
subject
step in nine describes Witnesses I'm
interested if there's more than one
document on this major Donald skijo and
if there is one document I would still
like it summarize for me
instead of having to read through this
sort of dense government paperwork
so I'm going to ask it to tell me about
major Donald Kehoe and see what pops up
and so again
takes a few seconds uh not too long
such as the nature of this being sort of
a Cutting Edge thing
all right oh I got quite a few snippets
on major Donald Kehoe this is sort of
interesting major Donald Kehoe was the
director of Nike the world's largest UFO
research organization
with over 30 subcommittees in the U.S
and abroad
he wrote the book aliens from space
believe that the Air Force was
suppressing information
uh he talked to Senator Barry Goldwater
so there's all these interesting things
and I can look at these sources and I
could dive deeper and deeper and learn
more and more things all day
and learn it so much quicker and easier
uh than sort of looking through dense
government paperwork
and so
uh
were able to uh I I know I watched them
with John greenwald's videos and he
always talks about
collecting the different stuff that
we're able to access publicly from the
government
the foyer request and collecting it into
important information and sort of
reading between the lines and seeing the
patterns emerged and in my opinion this
is such a perfect tool to do exactly
that
so I'm excited to see people play with
it I'm excited to see what they find uh
and I can't wait to see what kind of
questions people ask and what kind of
things people learn so you can go to
this website
theblacktolevault.com remember John's
website is The Black Vault so I just
made a pun and maybe this website will
change but regardless it's also in the
description the Black Toe Vault toe
vault.com this is a tool that will be
upgraded over time over time we'll put
in more features and there's even a
feature request like what are your use
cases what do you think this tool could
possibly do in the future what would you
like to see here's what I'd like it to
include in the let's say the next year
or so I'd like to implement let's say
gpt5 so that you can ask it context
aware queries like what are the
documents related to sightings of
triangular UFOs over military bases in
the 1970s and it just gives you those
answers with references to the official
government documents what are the common
explanations given by government
officials for sightings that occurred in
New Mexico in the 1960s let's say show
me the case that had the largest number
of Civilian eyewitnesses another
features that will have improved OCR so
right now we're only able to scan a
portion I'd like it to infer certain
contexts from redactive statements I'd
like it to have the automatic crawling
and indexing of new PDFs uploaded so
that is if you have a foia request or
some other government documents you'd
like to submit it then it can easily
ingest those and it doesn't have to go
through a whole re-ingesting of all of
the PDFs it can just take in new ones
I'd like to implement a time-based query
system to analyze changes in the
government's positions on certain topics
over a specific period I'd also like to
have a site map where we Implement a
global map of locations of UFO sightings
and the released files a Time series
analysis so you can see the again
frequency of UFO sightings over a
certain time and perhaps even scroll
through it UFO type classifier that's
interesting so classify the different
types of let the model the large
language model classify the different
types of UFOs based in the descriptions
of the documents a proximity search so
use the AI to help find UFO cases that
happen near to each other and so
propinquity and space and time I'd like
to have case comparisons so you can side
by side compare different UFO cases
eyewitness accounts aggregators collate
the eyewitness accounts related to
specific sightings it's an AI hypothesis
aggregator based on the context and the
content of documents the AI could
suggest possible explanations sentiment
analysis and of all then this one seems
like the most easily done so you can
analyze the sentiment toward UFOs within
the government documents predictive
analysis now that one's interesting
Implement a feature using whatever is
the most Cutting Edge tool to predict
Trends and patterns in UFO sightings
based on historical data
now all of these features every single
thing above all needs to be above board
and legal and also I'd like a developer
to come on and just take this over and
make this open source this way can be
maintained by the community and
transparent I'm already extremely packed
to the brim studying for tow episodes
for the theories of everything podcast
so if there's some one who wants to come
on and help out with this then please
let me know anyway you can enjoy the
website right now it's
theblacktovault.com and maybe this URL
changes because remember this is all
John's work just a bit of salt on his
decades-long sous-vide steak that's just
fall off the bone and and so toe is just
like a hair pinky nail Atop The Giant
shoulders of John the giant body of John
and in all respects so visit the website
theblacktovault.com final note to Big up
to Dan Dan VanZant the cephalopods AI
Solutions company Dan's a fantastic
coder but not only that he's able to
think creatively so I recommend Dan and
Dan's information is in the description
as well now if there's a philanthropist
who wants to donate to see this project
happen to actually come to the full
fruition of the vision of it then
definitely contact me and let me know
the contact information is on the
website you can also email toe Indie
filmto so
i-n-d-i-e-f-i-l-m-t-o.com also don't
forget this is John's work if you want
to donate to John which you should the
button is on the website as well and
it's also in this description remember
this is John's work
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy